all right so here I was at a Chicago as
a bridge in Chicago and I think that all
of us would agree that if you look at
this particular image and if you are
there you will look at all the
reflections okay but I was looking at
all the reflections and thinking they're
very abstract I couldn't get a clean
reflection I think most of us may may
have lay down on the ground and shot
upwards but it's all warping it doesn't
look that great we can get our lens
close to the reflective surface which of
course makes the reflection more vivid
but then the faces will warp it didn't
look right and I'm thinking well how
else can I use this particular texture
and surface so I'm thinking well
obviously we can just get someone away
from the background and that beautiful
warping can create a beautiful texture
in the background so I grabbed my
isolate for those of you don't know I
actually invented the isolate it's a
cylindrical base LED light it's a
glorified lightsaber I grew up with Star
Wars like most people and loved loved
that idea but anyway so this was done
with the eye slide and I took this shot
nothing fancy nothing incredible but you
would say that has a bit of a cinematic
look and a feel so that texture in that
environment gave me the idea that that
should be in the background and not so
obvious not so vivid but maybe what most
of us would not have done is decide to
flick that white balance to tungsten
which turns a day light into blue which
now makes you feel like this could have
been shot let's say a promo shot for
Blade Runner or something like that so
that's the idea is that many of us stick
to the standard way of doing things week
after week we we we tend to shoot the
same way expecting a different result
and of course if you do the same thing
over and over again expecting a
different result
that's a definition of insanity right so
we can't be insane we should look at an
environment and understand how to use it
now I've got to admit when I started
professionally even as a hobbyist
whenever I saw a great location I would
walk up to it I would always get my
couples against it so now I'm often
getting them away from the actual wall
away from that tree away from that
fountain and picturing everything out of
focus and the cool thing is you sort of
just squint in your environment and you
get an idea of what it looks like at a
focus then I thought well look let's not
waste there let's not waste the actual
moment
whenever I'm photographing let's say for
a wedding I'll photograph the guy
bringing the girl take them as a couple
bring the guy out then photograph the
girl now I've got three four spreads of
a wedding album so then we added the
girl and I thought how cool would it be
to get this strong lighting and split
lighting on his face split lighting is
where you eliminate one side of the face
and not the other often considered very
masculine and then that light bounces
off his face and gives that beautiful
glow here so he gets that harsh
masculine lighting and she gets that
police soft beautiful lighting as well
and of course I kept that daylight white
by the tungsten white balance white
balance that turns daylight into blue
and again it gives us this beautiful
look and feel now watch what all I do is
in camera change my crop and how much
more dramatic it actually looks that
caught something a little bit different
but most of us perhaps we just we may
not we may not try it we might always go
safe go wide go safe my suggestion to
you is if you're shooting for a client
do what you have to do to do what you
want to do make the client happy like
let's say make sure the parents are
happy who are traditional and then you
can go play and do what you want and
have some fun afterwards so here's Joe
illuminating the guys with the ice light
there and that sort of shows us the
behind the scenes then what I thought of
let's do like a groomsman kind of shot
and again this is using the tungsten
white balance and of course you can do
this after the fact if you're shooting
raw you can change the white balance
after the fact but often when you rely
on that you just don't do it if you do
it in camera it prompts you when you're
converting your files from raw to JPEG
and you're correcting them it actually
prompts you to actually see it straight
away and again being able to look at
that environment and maybe use your
groomers been in a very different way
you with me so far guys so we're
training our mind now to see the
environment and look at bad locations
and work out what to do with them
[Music]
now where do you think I photograph to
you I mean there's an arrow on the
ground telling you where I'm gonna
photograph you can see that skylight
above there this is an ordinary carpark
and then you've got the arrow right
there now what I'm looking for the
creative trigger here was I'm looking
for a little pocket of light so if I see
a glow of light on the ground I know
that basically the if someone's standing
there they're gonna get this beautiful
pocket of light on their faces so I need
an excuse to bring their face up to the
lights to actually get that shot so what
excuse could I give what do you do
naturally when you're pointing your face
upwards because after all if we're
shooting a wedding or a portrait session
or something like that we're directing
our couples most of the time but my
style is I like to direct my couples in
a way that appears natural like this
could have happened on its own so what i
did was i tilted her face and chin up
and then we ended up getting this shot
in this environment so let's say for
example your limo driver just drops you
off at the under a car park on the way
to the reception you could squeeze in
another spread of a wedding album by
simply photographing on the way to the
reception venue which is only 30 feet
away and that's what I'm saying is tilt
to face chin up
we're basically photographing on the
short side of the face often referred to
as the shadow side the short side the
narrow side I call it the sexy side and
we get that shot in the same vein I mean
again we're shooting here with the
fluorescent light on the rooftop of the
garage and I saw this this girl had this
incredible cheekbones and I'm like well
there's no better way to bring out
cheekbones and a light from above and of
course there were shots where they're
looking up to the light so they've got
catch lights in the eyes but I like the
idea of making it look more mysterious
and having these beautiful shadows on
her face and her cheekbones and then of
course again we give her reasons an
excuse to bring her chin up and I love
the fact we kept that little hint of
highlight on her cheek that just
separates her but again the environment
told me what to do the lights up above
what excuse can I have to bring
someone's face upwards and all I did now
for the next shot was changed my angle
and again what do you do you put your
chin up maybe the girls a little bit
shorter she's kissing she brings her
face up and then now
we get that kind of a shot pretty cool
any questions will come in so thoughts
from from our online audience ready go
that's a great comments Amanda just said
that I love what you said earlier about
shooting for the client and then shoot
for yourself because it feeds both needs
so if you feed your feed your clients
than that that's your business that's
how you're gonna make a living but then
you feed yourself and that that's your
soul so you can keep on going it helps
to prevent burnout and that kind of
thing and a lot of feedback about these
locations that you're shooting in like
under the bridge where it's just nothing
and especially those last few that you
showed with the garage because isn't it
crazy how these are just ugly locations
like a supermarket parking lot and so a
lot of times you know you clients are
like well where are we gonna do our
portraits where are we gonna do our
portraits and Jerry will often say do
you just have to trust me I'm always
gonna look for the light so he educates
them from the very beginning to say
we're just gonna walk around and I'm
gonna constantly be looking for the
light so that when Jerry does show up at
these locations to a photograph in a
supermarket garage they don't have an
issue with it and then they trust him
and end up with these beautiful
portraits so yeah lots of great feedback
keeps showing those and now why do I
challenge myself to go to these
locations really it's because they're
different in other words if I went to
the same park the same hotel then it's
going to just be coming so often I'll go
to a church and just do a 360 around the
church on the same block or as I'm
driving to a potential nominated
location I might in fact actually stop
three times as I'm as I'm driving there
so I'll tell a limo driver hey follow me
on the way to this location if I stop
you stop that means I want to shoot here
and that's why because I'm photographing
at so many different spots then I'm
getting diversity and I'm allowing the
environment to tell me what to do the
trigger is there the creative trigger is
there all you gotta do is pull it make
sense Garrett
can you ask that again just in case we
didn't catch the order in time was that
it was an afterthought it started off
with simply the light source so I wanted
to isolate the subject and what I always
do when I'm photographing are not only
photograph in a particular spot before I
break the the the the the the scene I
pressed the pause button in my mind and
I walk around the subject and I say well
if I was a second photographer now where
would I shoot from where would I go so I
think that that's what we do as
photographers we photograph one
dimensionally we look at a subject we
photograph in one way and we totally
forget to press the pause button
hey guys stay where you are and just
walk all around as a walk around it that
texture is really nice hey wait a second
what up what excuse me I could we have
for the both couple the couple to be in
that shot well what a couples do they're
romantic okay
maybe there adds a kiss or kissing
that's perfect because it brings her
face upwards great let me change the
environment bang so fantastic all right
audience at home how would you like to
win one of five annual memberships to
Gerry gear ins photography training
which we'll be announcing by the end of
this broadcast well here's your chance
maybe you want to talk about this okay
so to announce and celebrate the launch
of JG PT as we like to call it Gerry
June is photography training we're
giving away five memberships so we're
really excited here's what you have to
do open a new browser because we're
watching this in Facebook live and we
don't want to lose you brand new browser
you just chest thighs them guys go to
Jerry Jerry Jerry calm now I've been
seeing in the comments some of you have
been spelling Jerry with the G but it's
actually Jay so Jay
rry Jerry Jerry Jerry calm all you have
to do is enter your email address there
I will be monitoring that and then by
the end of this broadcast five of you
will get a brand new membership to our
website awesome thank you so much so
we're recently in Chicago walking the
streets at night so was doing a five
a workshop several months ago in Chicago
and I thought it was only unique to New
York but there was a manhole with just
smoke coming up now so if you were there
I'm sure you think well how do I use
this you walk in the streets I was
showing my students had a photograph at
night and basically using ambient light
using on-camera flash off-camera flash
continuous lights and things like that
so as we're walking across the road I
saw the steam coming up and of course if
you've ever back licked smoke you know
it's the best way to actually show off
smoke or whether it's cigars or or
whatever it may be so I have one of my
students over here with my SB 5000
firing the flash a little bit behind so
what I wanted to do is actually use this
flash not only to backlight the smoke
but to actually get a little hint of
light on the on the front of them as
well so then I thought alright
that was my creative trigger the actual
smoke now I need to give them an excuse
to be there and that's my encouragement
guys if you want something to look
glamorous and natural you want to make
something look like it is if it happened
on its own then what you need to do is
give them an excuse for example if you
see a bride and groom there's a
beautiful light falling on a nice wall
you stand them there some people will
just say we'll do what you want in our
photograph well I'm saying is give them
a starting point let it give them
something to do so what could they be
doing there maybe she's the bride's
picking up a dress looking over her
shoulder back at her man and then maybe
she's picking up a dress and they're
interacting and so on so she'll pick up
a dress she looked back at him he holds
a dress they look at each other don't
worry about the emotion yet get my
exposure to get my technique right and
then I'll now the expression in this
case I thought cool young couple
mysterious smoke that gives me the idea
for maybe a bit of mystery so I just get
them sort of walking across the street
so it's at some points the smoke would
come out quite big some a little bit
small something like this and I leave it
up to you to work out which one your
favorite is but at one point what I
decided to do is actually have her on
her own just jumping and then we ended
up getting this one I sort of wanted her
to almost be surprised as if this is a
car headlights hitting her or something
like that what sorry not hitting her may
be threatening and I think this was my
favorite in the
and because I quite love the very
dynamic sort of run and got that sort of
smoke sort of framing her quite
beautifully and and that worked out
really well it's just fun though isn't
it most of us we don't get play time on
a wedding day or a shoot because we
don't give ourselves that time when was
the last time you just went out and
photographed for yourself just to play
just to practice your craft so if you
only practice what you do for a living
on a paying gig then how do you expect
to be better all right let's look at the
next environment what do you think the
creative trigger here was so maybe from
our audience what do you think the
creative trigger was what what led like
what said to me oh my god this would be
great idea right now let's get your
microphone reflection from the building
okay so let's go let's go a bit deeper
now so if you walking if you're walking
across the street and then you see the
Sun hit a building and get'em blinding
your face then what is it what is the
light telling us it's giving us two
light sources right because one's from
behind then one's from the front so I'm
saying to you is whenever you walk along
the street and then you get blinded by
the reflection of a building or anything
then you know arguably you might have
the Sun hitting the back of you and of
course the sun's hitting your face which
means hey wait a second hey couple
bright stand where I'm standing turn
around now I have what appears to be
like a two light setup so that was the
light hitting them was the reflection
off the of the light of the building and
the light behind them was the Sun you
put it a dark background behind them
then now we've got this beautiful studio
set up right there and to remove
distraction I laid down and shut up
words and that's how we got that shot
all right let's keep on playing here so
we'll walk in the streets again that
same couple with a smoke and again what
was the creative trigger you know
anything could be a creative trigger
it's it can't just hit you in the face
you have to look for them for me it's
often light or it's texture it's
something as it is with most of us in
this case there was a beautiful glow of
light underneath the actual rail and the
stairs and I'm like well obviously no
just happens to sit underneath the
lights but it's obviously a stylized
fashionable editorial kind of image so I
thought why not let's say if you could
see me there I'm right up there shooting
down I exposed that beautiful light and
then turned her face and then we get
that shot in that environment now like I
said if I always ended up photographing
the predictable shots then this would be
on a street lamp this would be with
maybe some Christmas lights in the
background like most of us do but how
much fun would it be to actually do that
kind of a shot then introduce the groom
or the partner of the of the girl that
little hinted the reflection there and
now we have another spread either in a
portrait session album or a wedding
album that we wouldn't had in the first
place
make sense Justin how we feeling mate
good good I want to I want you to ask
the question sometimes for no reason
because I want to hear that beautiful
voice of yours again do you sing you
don't sing
what a waste man I would be I would be
putting on some who's that guy man I'm
like some Barry White
Barry White a hundred percent Teddy
Pendergrass I'd put him in as well
that's what I'd uh I promote you to sing
you'd be you'd kill it in the karaoke
contest but oh good maybe any other
questions or thoughts or comments yeah
we have a couple of really good thoughts
um someone had just to reiterate what
you said someone really like Kimberly
really liked that comment that you said
well you need to press the pause button
and then become your own second
photographer
it just means slowing down which is
something we always hear Jerry say is
slowing down we did have a question from
David asking you know these photos look
great that we're looking at how much
post-production was done on them are you
looking at like really retouched images
or what's what's going on there so some
of these images are retouched and some
of them are not but my retouching or the
retouching that we like to do is
actually very simple I like it invisible
and I guess that the best compliment
that we could have because you didn't
even know what we did the invisible
retouching that I call it is basically
what we call fashion retouching like if
I retouch skin you can see the pause I
don't use any action sets any keys or
any vignettes or anything like that
it's basically skin retouching and color
correction and that's basically it also
those of you who don't know we use a
company called lava Lou la vie ALU my
lava lucam and they're great for our
business they do all their albums and
they're fantastic
maybe another question that came up from
Santosh Gooden - ruh I hope I said your
name right Santosh I hope she's the
queen of pronouncing names but he had a
really good question you know because
you're showing these images and you're
showing these really great creative
crops that you're doing writing camera
the question is do you visualize the
crop that you take before you take the
shot or do you take a few different
crops all in the same location and then
work out which one you like better at
the end I love to crop in camera
personally I what I look at something I
really said it myself well what's the
best part about this image like I could
be posing a full-length image and
thinking you know what it's not working
but what is really beautiful is right
there so I love dissecting things I love
cropping things and what I like to do is
put two faces together and bodies
together like a puzzle imagine two
pieces of a puzzle putting it together
so the way I teach posing and I'll do
that in upcoming presentations and live
broadcast for jgb tea is I like to
understand how two faces can fit in
together like a puzzle if that happens
it's aesthetically pleasing and it works
really really well so I'm very much an
in-camera cropping kind of a guy Garrett
I shoot just a little bit loose for a
like eight by ten cup position or do you
keep it two by three
I always keep it two by three I don't
sell anything other than 2 by 3 ratio to
my clients so for example back in the
old days it'll be five by four or five
by seven eight-by-ten 11:14 what do I
sell now four by six five seven and a
half eight by twelve ten fifteen and so
on and so on and so on I encourage you
to just go for it as in don't be too
safe what's the worst that can happen I
mean you're there to tell a story so
when I crop I crop for so many different
reasons and I will be presenting this in
upcoming episodes on JG BT of Y cropping
is so important in fact more so do you
remember we had a very emotional week
for one of some of the students and our
workshops and we talked about cropping
and then she ended off talking about as
we talk about work-life balance and she
made this reference to cropping as a
metaphor for work-life balance but also
the way I teach cropping yeah so it was
it was funny because the first part of
our week during the workshop is really
about the technique part of it posing
lighting and that stuff and we're
getting into the meat of photography
itself and then we spend a lot of time
at the end is Jerry said talking about
business and marketing and how to make
more money from your business so that
you can spend time with your family and
enjoying life and it does get emotional
because we worked so hard and sometimes
we don't make a lot of money doing what
we do and when you learn how to get to
that point where you can enjoy your life
it's it's a big epiphany
so as Jerry was saying you likes to crop
in camera and so we were saying you know
you just crop the distractions out when
you're at a location especially you see
the locations that Jerry shoots at and
garages and train stations and stuff you
need to crop that out so you're not
seeing any of those distractions in the
background but in life there's a lot of
stuff that goes on that's distracting to
you and that's that gets in your way and
gets in the way of your goals and what
she said at the end she's I think my
biggest Epiphany this week is that you
just have to crop the crap ahead of your
life and then everything is better and
it's the same for photography you just
crop the crap out of your images and it
looks better in life you crop the crap
the negativity the stuff that you don't
need and you're much more focused and
you're much happier and that's as bad as
much as Melissa will swear on camera at
the very least yes thank you baby she
was like crap we have another question
for now what about audiences Joe do you
have a question yeah speaking of the
crap and the pictures you're shooting
garages on stairs and public areas not
the cleanest places how do you get your
clients to agree to lay down on stairs
going into a subway or something like
that man that's a great question see
it's all it all depends on the trust
that you build beforehand and as also
depends on the way you ask so the
classic example that I give one day to
you know is so you could look at a bride
she has this beautiful wedding dress and
you
this killer shot that you want to do all
that needs is for her to sit on the
ground with a dress and you might say oh
I've got an idea for a shot your dress
might get a little bit dirty but it's
really worth it
so that puts fear of the fear into them
right I might say something like I've
got an incredible idea for a photograph
I want you to lie down the ground bring
your backside really close to the wall I
want you to bring your legs up just
cross them bend them slightly just lift
your dress down a little bit
arch your back put your chin up turn
your face and look right into my camera
I practically made love to the bride
just with my words but I solved that the
appeal of the shot
I didn't bring attention to maybe the
dress might get dirty certainly I'm not
gonna be stupid about putting it on in a
in some dust or dirt or anything like
that but if she says aw I love the idea
but I don't feel comfortable I'll tell
you what how about I unravel my
reflector bring it on the ground and
would you be happy to lie down on my
reflector oh my god fantastic I'll just
crop it out so you won't see it but
that's how I do it make sense Bertha
guys well let's keep let's keep finding
these triggers let's see if we can
identify them how many times have you
walked past the sign and never thought
of it as a light source I can't tell you
how many people will walk past a sign
like this and that is a perfect
continuous light softbox
the kind that are illuminating me here
right now so what I do is I bring my
subjects really close and what do we do
we crop the crap out and we get these
beautiful shots here I mean you couldn't
ask for a better light source could you
all we need to do and for those of you
watching at home who are inexperienced
you might say well what does good light
mean what does good posing mean
certainly we'll cover that properly in
upcoming episodes of JG Beatty but
really most of the time what I do and
most people do will turn a face into a
light source until the eye that's close
to the camera the complete eye socket
gets in lights and we have beautiful
catch lights in the eyes but good
lighting good posing could be defined as
flattering and/or it helps communicate a
message that you are trying to convey to
the viewer as the artist but you can see
though that how clean that is
and we crop
and how much of a feeling that gives us
once you start looking at these triggers
you'll see them everywhere everywhere
hey hope you're enjoying the video so
far we still have more to go so don't go
anywhere but I just wanted to pause to
remind you to click on that subscribe
link below so you always stay up to date
when we add new videos and you never
miss out on a thing and if you want more
videos like this make sure you go to
giannis calm and sign up for a
subscription so you can access so many
videos just like this 24/7 now back to
the video so I was walking I think this
is a rare day a drive at nighttime and I
saw this sort of translucent glass and a
bit of a glow behind it and I thought
wait a second if I grab my the model
really really close to the actual wall
I'll not only eliminate her I might get
a two or three reflections out of it as
well and that that's how we've got these
shots it's just fun man and it's fun to
challenge yourself and to try something
a little bit different something new
rather than always relying on location
number 23 pose number 27
you know then what I did is I thought
let's not stop there my encouragement
you're watching it at home and you guys
in the room is take that first shot then
say to yourself well what we'll go with
it in an album so I want you to start
thinking about actually shooting for
what you're going to sell which again
we'll cover in upcoming topics but in
this case she stayed there we brought
her boyfriend in France eliminated him
and then we had turns of her looking and
him being suggested and then of course
switching that role now wouldn't that
make a great spread in a wedding album
that took me two shots I think many of
us what we would have done here
we may have photographed a 30 or 40 or
50 to get just - I'd rather you slow
down and take maybe five and you'll sell
to rather than take fifty insult -
you're wasting your time that make sense
alright now what happens if you have no
trigger if there's literally a blank
canvas there's nothing but a concrete
wall and you think what the hell am I
going to do with that that's
seat guys sometimes you just have to
create yourself the trigger has to be
well if I had a blank canvas and I had
some paint what would I do in this case
I'm thinking concrete very sunny and I'm
thinking all right well maybe we can
split light the groom or the guy and
then maybe use a strong shadow on the
concrete and then introduce an element
of the background and then we get this
image not that it's an incredible image
an award-winning image but perhaps it's
pretty fun for for the location that we
had to deal with then I literally turn
around 180 degrees and I see this
location now what was the trigger well
it's the beautiful texture of the the
lights and the shade going down now what
I want you to do is remember this
comment you want to crop you want to
remove context to improve mystery now
what does that mean context we're at a
garage you can see the gap between the
pillars that's the context I don't want
that for now where I am that it's boring
it's just stupid so I take a few steps
to the right and let these overlap each
other crop into it get my guy right
there because I need now a shot to
complement the previous one done i if i
want to sell the spread of a wedding
album and i get this make sense if i was
loose and wide i would good at the
context that yes i might crop it after
the fact but the proofs that go to the
client don't look as good as what i was
expecting with my vision straight away
make sense
speaking of masculine sort of shots and
things like that what was my creative
trigger here it's pretty obvious but
what would you do here what what would
some of us do here do you think maybe in
our audience you look at that particular
location what's a cool thing to try out
here yep sure I would try posing them in
the light and having a dark shadow
behind them fantastic I saw something
like this fantastic so I'm saying to you
is that we see the Sun crop shadows and
create beautiful strong lines almost
everywhere
sometimes when you're so absorbed in
your camera and the event or you're
under pressure with totally
all these things so the trigger was
pocket of light nice shade that reminds
me it's strong that's harsh there's a
strong line that reminds me of masculine
energy let me put the groom there and
that's it now you might say well Jerry
how do I get him to look at the camera
when it's really really sunny and he's
squinting all day long well I might get
him to look at a certain spot and he's
doing this and then I just say all right
just
okay so close your eyes on a count of
three look at me one two three click and
he could squeak all day long but I've
got that shot that I want and I'm and
I'm fine
see guys don't handle the Sun nowhere
near as good as girls can't guys are
like a bit you know they're a bit soft
when it comes to those kinds of things
that they they women tolerate pain a lot
more than a lot more than men all right
same location a different couple how
many times when was the last time you
photographed a couple at f-22 most of us
don't do that do we we shoot at shallow
depth of field two point eight one point
four F 2 F 4 and so on and so on and so
on but most of us don't think about
actually increasing that aperture to
create an unusual effect Justin got a
question so what I did was I placed so
the trigger again was there I thought
wouldn't it be cool to put the groom
with the shadow behind him and the girl
with a light so dark and light and like
think of all those metaphors so I did
this shot now you would swear that was a
composite or a composite as the
Americans would say I'm American now so
as we say so this shot they were
standing about 3 4 feet away from each
other but I showed 22 now I know it
seems obvious but when was the last time
you did that
probably never so most people would
shoot 2 exposures for this or you know
HDR or something like that but I think
it's fun to just try some different
things baby girl people are bored of my
face I should see your face any
questions or thoughts or comments
um just a few things that have come up
people are asking which I forgot to
mention earlier so I'm sorry about that
but where will they be able to see this
video so I just want to quickly divert
and say this is being broadcast live on
Facebook right now so if you're not able
to watch the whole thing or if you're
missing part of it no
just come back to Jerry's Facebook page
at any time the video will stay on here
so you can rewatch it anytime that you'd
like it will always be here so just
touching on that but I just wanted to
first do a couple quick little feedbacks
that were really awesome
Ron Joe said a really great point
because earlier you talked about slowing
down and how that's such a key because
in being able to see things actually
being able to look at everything in your
environment and he said I love that slow
down and pause comment he's been
shooting for almost 50 years and it's
becoming easier easier to do that both
mentally and physically so this is
coming from an experienced veteran in
our industry
who's saying that the more that you
shoot the more they the longer you think
you've been a photographer the easier it
gets so don't get discouraged if you
still freaked out when you go to a shoot
and you're at a wedding and you just
don't see everything until after the
fact it's okay just keep keep that in
your mentality keep that in your mind as
you're out shooting and it will come the
more you keep trying to practice it the
more it will happen we have had a couple
of questions two really good questions
actually baby a one quick one a lot of
people who are asking how high are you
happy to go with your ISO and those
night shots that we were showing earlier
I mean some it was really dark some of
them are at midnight and stuff so how
high are you happy to go with your
camera well I mean obviously with the
latest cameras they're incredible you
mean you can you can crank them up
ridiculously being an economist I'm very
proud to submit Nicole ambassador I have
all the latest greatest cameras the D at
50 is incredible to defy but I mean
we're talking 12,000 800 easily you
don't mean I think many of us freaked
out what ten thousand ISO or what's a
couple gonna say I think we as
photographers overthink the quality of a
high ISO image way more than couples do
has a bride ever said to you you know
what I know you're not shooting with a
d5 because I can see people fringing in
the shadow areas and really the noise
levels are terrible I mean no the
bride's gonna say that now yes we don't
want to provide crap to our clients but
think about it if you're shooting at
night it's probably at a reception maybe
in a church you're probably not going to
enlarge those much anyway so just don't
ever think it crank the ISO up find your
threshold and stick with it but push it
a bit further than you than you think
sorry for me easily 12,800 and beyond
yep another we've had a couple people
that miss the link to don't forget we're
giving away five memberships to our
online training site our brand new one
JG Petey Jerry units Photography
training you have to go to Jerry Jerry
Jerry calm I know a couple people missed
that so I want to quickly interject that
but a question related to what you're
teaching at the moment baby is from
Michelle Alton she said do you scout out
the areas for these triggers like to
find the best areas that will provide
you with these triggers before you bring
a client's out for shoot because I don't
know that too many people will plan
their wedding portraits to happen under
a bridge or a garage so do you pre Scout
any of that stuff well let's let's talk
about just normal locations for a moment
so I don't want to go extreme so for
example let's maybe relate it let me ask
the question for you perhaps and give
you a more broader answer that might be
more appealing to the broader audience
do i scout locations period so if I'm
photographing a wedding at this place or
whatever do I go there beforehand to
look at it well here's the thing
unless I'm photographing the wedding or
the portrait session at the exact time
that I'm at the exact same time that I'm
scouting it there's a really no point
now yes I could create the good light or
find the good light and just make it
work no problem but I usually like to
use the light that's there if I need to
add light with a speed light a
continuous light a strobe and of course
I'll do it so very rarely will I go to
the location and look around and see
what I'm going to do that being said if
you shoot a wedding that you've never
been to before like at location and it's
a big hotel or it's a big mansion then
walk around at least know the
possibilities and other priorities and
at least in your mind you'll say alright
okay if all weather's good and lighting
is good I will go to the here here here
and here and here and here is a bonus
but I'm telling you now I there's a I
don't know for many of you at home or
you and the room guys that you remember
this photograph that I've taken on that
gold staircase sort of one of my legacy
shots you'd call them
it's a bride lying down with a beautiful
gold staircase I went to house
overlooking the Harbour Bridge in Sydney
and I get there the house is a beautiful
house but
dark there was no where inside the house
that actually looked good that made them
the the bride shine bright and guess
where I photographed in the front study
where they put all of their crap from
the other rooms to make all the other
rooms look beautiful but they put it all
in the front room so I went in the front
room and stacked all the crap out and
simply drew the the warm translucent
blinds and it gave me this perfect swarm
softbox and they trusted me and I ended
up doing 90% of my coverage right there
for those of you this is really weird
actually not I society members for those
of you Gerry gear owners photography
training members that could be found on
the wedding shoots area under John and
Monica and the bride's coverage and it's
crazy you'll see how how much fun we had
there so look don't be a hero and never
Scout anything know where you're
shooting go for it but unless you're
shooting at the exact same time it will
all change on the day of the shoot
alright let's let's keep on going shall
we what was the trigger here what do you
think the trigger was here well we've
got a beautiful textured wall but
whereabouts on the textured wall would
be fun to shoot what's begging to be
done what do you think you see that
beautiful little arch of that shadow
maybe we can have some negative space
now the sun's coming up really really
high down low so we need an excuse to
bring their face upwards now remember
this to that one strong direction of
light to people interacting one person
suffers that's just a fact you will
never get perfect lighting on two people
with one direction of light when they're
interacting the only way you would do it
is with a reflector but then that's too
almost to call it two directions of
light in this case then she gets the
good light the negative space is there
and that's basically it now again this
is not going to win any awards but I'm
trying to show you these triggers that
help and make you understand perhaps all
the things you've been missing off all
the years now how many times have you
actually walked into a bedroom and
you've seen blinds being pulled down
because it's actually very very hot and
you see a little glow of light
reflecting off the wall did you think
that you could easily just walk up pull
that up
and now all of a sudden we have this
beautiful reflector and now we get this
shot and you would swear that was
probably done in the studio all with a
nice slide or something so remember
every time you see a blind like that
bring them back this is at a workshop in
Turkey so you might think do I have like
300 assistants on a wedding day and
that's how this was taken nowt so many
people ask me about the following shot
so I will be showing one older one that
you may have seen before but for those
of you at home who haven't seen this for
those of you in the room that haven't
seen this everyone asked me about it so
I thought I'd actually show you and it's
also a great lesson on finding and
learning from those creative triggers so
what was my creative trigger here well
the bride was inside the house I was
with the groom were walking outside so
if you can imagine so if imagine this
this TV represents the window of the
house so I'm basically walking the groom
is between me and the house and as I was
walking I of course you walk like this
as I was a woman as I was walking I saw
the reflection of his silhouette against
the overcast sky but then as he crossed
the bride
I saw her vividly through that
reflection I thought wait a second here
without being all romantic and
lovey-dovey about it all but maybe we
can actually produce an image that
there's a metaphor of to becoming one of
a bride and groom becoming one so what I
did was I asked if I had a letter small
little one I did they stood he stood in
a letter so I can get him perfectly in
that overcast sky so if you can imagine
now I'm seeing a reflection of his
silhouette in the glass then if she
comes now through that actual silhouette
now I will see her face merged into his
silhouette and we actually get this
image it's actually quite surreal the
more you look at it the more you see
like the fact that his shoulder looks
like her shoulder almost his hair looks
like her hair like almost like a modern
haircut of her you know almost like you
wake up maybe go
but that's what I'm trying to say is
that how could it be to recognize those
things but they're not just going to hit
you in the face you have to look for
them hopefully after today's
presentation we have not over to given
you very tangible ideas that if you see
a blind you'll do it if you see a
fluorescent light in the garage you'll
do it but that'll give you an idea of
how to use the environment other ways
for examples that you haven't seen now
what do we see here now this is Bryant
Park libraries that what it is baby
but it's just next door to Bryant Park
okay
all right wonderful so we're at this
location in New York and I'm sure many
of us would use as a background maybe
get them on the steps maybe use this the
wall maybe get the couple away from the
background things like that and the more
I looked at it I thought I saw this
particular sort of rail there and I'm
looking at these things I'm like wait a
second if I was to walk all around there
and shoot back that way I might get a
really really cool view now nothing
groundbreaking or anything like that but
I think many of us we tend to see what's
obvious first there's no creative
trigger it had to hit us in the face
great location let me just shoot there
whatever and then I go down that rail
and shoot up I think it was basically
like a wheelchair access to get to the
library and there was too many people
going in and out as I was photographing
and there was too much distraction so I
just got rid of a distraction I just
pose my my group fear and got rid of
them totally now we've got great
reactions and things like that all that
all is good but then I wanted to
photograph with my beautiful juicy 105
millimeter one-point-four lens that
makes everything look incredible in the
background because you can imagine the
trees in the background and the lamp in
the background and everything would look
incredible the problem is too many
people walking in and out now I'm not
gonna sit there and photograph and just
ask my retoucher can you get rid of
those people I'm a I'm a purist at heart
certainly I do what I do afterwards in
post-production but if I can do it in
camera I will sure enough we took about
20 shots I had a leg in there I had a
head in there and we finally got the
shot that we were looking for in the
beginning now that beautiful light we
had the sunlight reflecting off the
opposing building coming in this way I
wanted a quiet moment between the
couple do you notice something here the
hands are exposing the thinnest part of
her waist I think many of us when we
pose a guy or you know hugging a girl
it's always actually covering up the
thinnest part of her waist
what a waste of a waste okay so bring
those back we actually Bend that mean a
little bit to create a little bit of
separation and the leg beautiful you see
how are the faces fit like a puzzle as
we're discussing and then those hands
are saying something remember what we
said good lighting good posing is either
flattering and/or it helps communicate
the message that we're trying to convey
to the viewer make sense so we got that
from that kept on walking the streets
what else do we see here well what was
the trigger
well the Chrysler Building what I mean I
probably my favorite building in in New
York City beautiful building but then
I've got deep shadow I've got strong
highlight well what the hell do I do I
think most of us would probably have
come to the conclusion that we'll get
some maybe off-camera flash will expose
for the background and get some
off-camera flash and that's exactly what
I did now this time though what I did
was I actually flicked my white balance
to shade that actually makes the flash
look like a video light because I didn't
really have a diffuser I didn't really
have anything with me other than a bare
bulb flash and then we ended up getting
this shot what you probably don't know
for me too
up for me to get this perspective get
the hints of the Chrysler Building there
and crop the crap out as we discussed I
had to lie on the ground and shoot
upwards now here's a very important tip
whenever you're lying down the ground or
squatting down and shooting upwards with
a wide-angle lens if you're couples stay
straight like this then it's gonna look
like they're doing that they're gonna
look really terrible what you don't know
in this in fact he's leaning forward
literally about this much and I've
cropped the awkwardness out so you don't
see it but you would swear he was
standing normally I have a gap between
his arms that also provide a silhouette
for him because most of us think of the
silhouette for the girl to get her shape
but you don't want to make him look
white either we turn his face into the
light source another little tip is this
have you ever actually had an off-camera
flash with your what one of your
assistants illuminating somebody
and then they have to fire if you have
to fire the shot like three four times
to get the flash in the right spot
here's a tip so let's say Justin of
course Justin so if you're there Justin
and where I want to illuminate you and I
just say - my assistant well I'll spend
forty five degrees and just point it
towards Justin well it's a hit and miss
what I want to do is I want to create a
shadow on the side of the face as close
to the camera therefore creating the
short side the narrow side the sexy side
make you look slimmer and sharper so
what I do is I tell my assistant when
you're holding the flash I want you to
draw an imaginary line from your eyes
your face to the flash and keep on going
until you can just see the other eye
socket does that make sense so if you
were photographing me and this was the
flash right you might say the assistant
just photograph this way but draw an
imaginary line between the eyes of the
assistant the flash pointed towards me
and keep on going when you just see this
eye socket why do I say I suck it
because you could have half the eye look
a bit creepy keep on going
fire the flash once and guess what
perfect shadow both eyes perfectly lit
and we get it every single time
all right any questions from our
audience or maybe any any questions from
our audience
back online I feel I can I can
definitely do that so I just wanted to
say a quick little I know I keep giving
feedback but lucho sort of really nice
comment where he said that he started
following you since he started
photography seven years ago and he's
been struggling with it and working
really hard but he's always challenging
himself and you've been really inspiring
for him so he wanted to say thank you
that was really really awesome what's
his name his name is Lucho
Lucho have I met Lucho I don't know
actually
I don't know um Lucho thank you for your
support thank you for growing up with me
I'm mother doesn't know this I want to
give you a year membership to the new
training site
Melissa hook him up I will hook you up
put your brother up I'll take care of
after the broadcast I'll hook you up on
a flipside
Melanie Cassie's wrote a comment to say
by the way Jerry is her Kitty's name
love that her cat's name is cherry there
are so many lines right now don't say
that word I will not say this thank you
thank you there are so many lines baby
you don't feed me that and not expect me
to say anything alright let me well Jake
well Jake afterwards with a steak with a
celebratory drink afterwards but all
right guys moving on alright
it was muggy as hell oh my god have you
ever shot in Florida I've in Miami and
all that kind of thing it's it's crazy
well actually was this was this Miami
where was it there we go we this was at
a workshop yes where did we photograph
this one again it was all Maggie and
misty and all that kind of stuff anyway
it was one of those places that was
pretty muggy so we're walking past this
restaurant and it was all foggy it
reminded me of the Titanic scene you
know when they were doing it in the
ending thing and like Chicago uh it was
it was all it was all misty got really
muggy there we go so I thought all right
how about we exposed to that background
so basically the mist the fog the lights
in the background was my trigger then I
thought we'll get them in the way and no
matter where I put them there was
spotlights giving me some really ugly
light falling on their faces now for me
to under expose the background there was
still that light in their faces so I
placed my reflector on top of them to
get it clear clear path then I under
expose the backgrounds and we get
something like this and then why
wouldn't we in this kind of a situation
crop a bit closer how cool is it that we
can actually get a shot like this that
actually gets their profile perfectly
sharp and then that little eyelash on
the other side some may consider
distracting I think it looks really
really cool it's also out of focus but
this beautiful little profile between
them at form a little puzzle can you
imagine that at the end of an album and
then blending this into black and a big
panorama like this how cool would that
be but something so
simple we have to look at that
environment and recognize those triggers
but also look for them that's the whole
idea
now when walking past this location and
as you know I'm a big fan of any light
source if it illuminates I'll use it so
I'm walking down the stairs and then I
shoot from above and I shoot down and I
take this shot and I've got to say it's
a boring shot it's a well lit boring
photograph
all right well wait a second let's
explore this location a little bit more
so then I thought wait a second that
light source if I squat down the stairs
and shoot this way then I'm actually
gonna get the light falling on the
couple and a quite a beautiful abstract
reflection so I get this image so there
was someone on the other side
illuminating her with a nice light and
then I look at that reflection I'm like
that's worth a shot on its own but how
cool would that be on a canvas print as
a talking piece on the wall in your
lounge room for example and that's a
whole other seminar guys but I I
sincerely and strongly believe in the
power of print it brings you to actually
to discuss as well I'm if you go into
PPA guys and I've quite a few of few
people are traveling to PPA today but
you can certainly watch this in the
reruns but on Monday and Monday morning
I'll be presenting a seminar along with
some incredible friends and family are
what I consider my chosen family Luke
and David Edmondson about the power of
print and there'll be a whole discussion
based upon that on the Monday morning
and then on Tuesday morning I'll be
discussing how to actually sell an album
and upsell it and handle objections and
and what do you do if someone wants
JPEGs only and things like that we'll be
discussing all that so if you're gonna
be in Nashville I'll see you Monday
morning at 8:30 sharp and as well as
Tuesday as well so that'll be a lot of
fun any questions from our audience or
you guys here at all you're cool all
right let's move on all right guys now
what's my trigger here this is a pretty
boring shot but what's my trigger the
trigger is that beautiful little
silhouette of the foliage with a
beautiful glow from behind but I need to
isolate that to get that romance so what
did I do
I brought out the ice light I illuminate
her and I wanted a quiet little what I
call a moment between a moment not so
obvious so I get her in light a little
semi silhouette of him and that
beautiful glow behind that gives us a
beautiful sort of feeling you know let's
keep on going let's just build our
creative muscle now about how to
actually really start to see the world a
little bit differently now many of us
probably have seen and photographed with
Christmas lights like at nighttime you
see Christmas lights and we always think
of that bokeh effect we get someone in
the foreground and so on well you only
see a few of them in a tree during the
day but if you get a couple way way way
in the foreground expose for them and
have that sort of out of focus it can
add a beautiful little element to a shot
of course the brightest part of the
image is still this but that just makes
it interesting to look at so makes it
fun fun fun all right
I told you early in the presentation
that I'm a very proud of Nakano
ambassador and probably one of my
proudest moments of my careers last year
I was chosen to do the campaign for the
Nikon v8 50 and not only did we
represent the the wedding genre but also
the fashion genre as well which I was
really really excited about and this was
actually Las Vegas suddenly if you guys
have been there before this is called
the Parisian palace in Las Vegas and
incredible ornate location you imagine
like Yanni Versace and Roberto Cavalli
had a lovechild and built a house that's
what this particular house looks like
it's incredible so anyway I thought I
can photograph the reflection it sort of
seemed obvious that if we're in this
location that we would photograph the
reflection but then I like what's
obvious I may have done that but the
frame actually was incredible so let me
just photograph her there now you can
see that she's standing next to a window
so there's a window next to her on the
left hand side of her and there's a
little window behind the mirror so I
thought this is perfect this is just a
studio setup I can include the gold
frame in the actual shot illuminate her
from the front with a little tickle of
light in her face and have a little
accent light on her jaw in the back of
her
the problem was the Sun was coming
strongly and vividly on his shoulder and
I just couldn't get rid of it now you've
got exposing for that kind of light and
the sunlight hitting the shoulder you're
not going to resurrect that in Photoshop
it's gonna be almost impossible to do it
well so Melissa was wearing socks got an
attacker for socks rolled them up and I
waged it between the mirror and the
actual wall that blocked off that
spotlight after this shot was taken I
got the guy involved and we ended up
doing this image so this was
photographed at one point for I love
that plane of focus he got her eyelid
there and her lips beautifully perfectly
in focus and then how important is that
little gap between the nose and the
forehead if it was joint it would be
okay I prefer it overlap properly
because if that was touching it just
like that it actually makes his nose
look pronounced hashtag bigger which we
don't want
and then how important is that I have
that little gap above his ear and how
important is that I have a little bit of
separation beyond that corner and then
we have all those beautiful tones mixing
and heart
harmonizing together for your beautiful
effect cool cool hey hope you're
enjoying the video so far we still have
more to go so don't go anywhere
but I just wanted to pause to remind you
to click on that subscribe link below so
you always stay up to date when we add
new videos and you never miss out on a
thing
and if you want more videos like this
make sure you go to Gyoen is calm and
sign up for a subscription so you can
access so many videos just like this
24/7 now back to the video I talked
about Christmas lights
and I'm sure some of us have done this
in the past this is the classic shot
that most people would have done if you
thought of you have weddings or couples
so I saw these Christmas lights in my
environment I grabbed the couple that
she looks like Melissa a little bit
don't you think quite crazy reminded me
a dream that I once had with two
Melissa's no I'm a joke
so we had two the couple looking at each
other my recommendation is this so if a
couple of facing each other have your
assistant whoever's holding the flash or
whether it's on a stand about six feet
away from them
never have the flash too low it's
just too low it'll hit light up here and
it'll dwindle off and you won't get that
beautiful light around their profile so
my advice to you is if you've got a
bride a bride here and a groom here then
that light should be six feet behind and
as high up as possible on the same level
and I usually use the groom to hide the
flash so what my recommendation is get
yourself a little monopod put your flash
on it put it up and then that monopod
and that flash is hidden behind the
groom turn the flash so it bounces
perfectly in the middle of the couple
bouncing between given that beautiful
glow in this case this next chart for
the campaign I wanted to actually test
the cat the high ISO capability the D at
50
hence sort of emulating a shot that I
popularize over the years but what I did
though
I brought the groom a little bit closer
to me so the flash hits his face and she
gets a bit more pretty alight does that
make any sense now then it's funny I
sort of made them laugh and at one
particular point I got that you know
that's smoking a can type thing so we
got the smoke in a can that emulates
sort of dustin and environment and all
that kind of stuff so we had this sort
of remnants of the smoke sort of
filtering across I made them laugh she
moved forward the cool thing was the
flash hit his face perfectly now as a
perfect reflector back on her and we get
this shot so I like I love the fact that
he's almost in silhouette and it it
almost looks out of focus but if you I'd
trust me if you go close to it you'll
see her eye perfectly sharp this so it
was a bit of a bit of luck that grabbed
the focus there when I was photographing
it as they moved when I made them laugh
out of the shot you have a question no
all right you just look very intent so
good I'm grabbing your attention which
is awesome
all right let's move on this is a really
cool location in Melbourne I was doing
this portrait and I was shooting at a
very shot at the field I think it was
1.4 I think with the 85 at this point
and then I thought to myself all right
this is great everything's that a focus
beautiful bokeh effect looks all cool
but how cool would it be to actually
maybe bump up the light on her face
narrow the light down so I used the ice
light with barn doors or barn doors as
you would say
and narrow it down and under expose the
background so I'm using the ice light
with the barn doors and then we end up
getting a shot like this so beautiful
quality of light very very soft you sort
of see as well how we've got the the
lips parted as well if you ever want to
make lips that are small or bigger
actually look even softer and bigger
again is I always ask my models my
subjects to breathe through your mouth
but not like that's silly right like
just part the lips enough to breathe
through the mouth that reminds the model
to relax the lips and without pouting
because some people have seen America's
Next Top Model and then they all start
pouting and then everyone parts and this
looks ridiculous so little things like
that can really really help you alright
so here I was in a this was where was
this this was in Melbourne this was at a
business centre in in a hotel okay so
what was the trigger what am I looking
for here what was the creative trigger
that made me shoot here well as I walked
into that particular little alcove there
I saw a translucent saz film or sticker
whatever going to call it on that piece
of glass straightaway I said to myself
silhouette because I could place someone
in the path have a nondescript
background and then all the sudden get
this perfect little profile it didn't
stop there
so I set them up I expose basically
exposed for the background which could
make that the couple go dark with less
detail but then in a business center you
normally see computers I saw an iMac so
I position my my camera my lens close to
the reflective surface and then I ended
up doing this shot but how cool would
that be in a spread of a wedding album
now you have to build enough trust of
course to shoot this kind of thing with
a couple because they want to photograph
next to that fountain and here you are
in a business center photographing next
to a translucent piece of glass and the
reflection of an iMac which is quite
ridiculous but if you build enough trust
and you take
shot me show them then I'll do anything
for you for the rest of time don't you
think
cool cool alright how about our audience
what's the trigger here what do you
think I did here I'm sort of pretty much
telling you by showing you the behind
the scenes photograph but what was the
trigger
and how would I use it Justin to be the
light on our back in whatever that
structure is to her right yeah so what
do you when you look at that what do you
think of what's the like and don't the
answer is not difficult it's just that's
that's this thing we tend to
overcomplicate in the environment where
we don't look at it from what it is what
is that what is that that we all have in
the back of our car in the trunk of our
car what is exactly what you're seeing
here what is this
and what kind of reflector is it yeah
well it's a silver one right if it's a
silver reflector does that make it
softer a bit more contrast in sharper
cover the microphone so think about it
say we it's specular yes a specular it's
more contrast it's sharper it's gonna be
punchy er so all I do is I crop the crap
out and I get that beautiful little
highlight and behind her head and then
we ended up photographing this and you
would swear that was done in the studio
well really I made that the studio was
already there I decide to find it and
that's what I'm getting at is that many
of us don't look at the environment
either like a studio or we don't
recognize or look for those creative
triggers and sometimes it could be so
obvious but it's sometimes it's the most
obvious things you don't even see
because they're so obvious it's just
there you take it for granted make sense
but pretty cool to be able to get that
shot from that environment and I could
show you the original image and it
wasn't too different than than what I've
done with the post-production all right
okay what do you see here what was my
creative trigger what what obviously
would I want to get in this shot
the skyline okay so it's pretty obvious
we want to get the skyline so generally
speaking if you know me or you
you've been taught by me you know that
I'll always choose light above location
but if I find a great location with
not-so-great lights I will create the
good light of find the good light so
what's the problem here if I expose for
that what's gonna happen in the
foreground it's gonna be dark so what do
I have to do fill light so maybe
off-camera flash so the environment told
me that basically said Jerry if you want
that city and you shooting up above here
there's a little balcony then obviously
get the couple over here and shoot down
and have the water envelop their faces
and frame their faces that's basically
it so then what I did I do I grab my
off-camera flash what did I do I draw an
imaginary line my assistants eye to the
flash to the person's eye moved it to a
point where we can just see what's going
on
it illuminates the eye socket closest to
the camera I changed my white balance to
cloudy to add a little bit of warmth to
make the flash almost look like video
lights a tungsten video light to a
certain extent and then we get this shot
what else is this environment telling us
I want you to look at the environment
we've taken the obvious shot what else
is the environment telling us what else
is the creative trigger literally
screaming and saying shoot me here the
Sun the Sun all right and what else what
what are the other thing in that
particular photograph and that
behind-the-scenes photograph what is
basically saying photograph me here I'm
giving you an excuse to be here and to
take this photograph what is it
the leading lines are the walkway
certainly but we're gonna have the same
problem so we're going to have the flash
and all that kind of stuff but what
happens if we don't want to do flash
anymore we simply just want to use the
quality of light from the Sun in a
certain way what could they be doing in
that environment my question would be
the the light that's sitting on the rail
is that from another source is that from
something else actually that's just that
was the flash that fired during the
behind-the-scenes photograph for
teaching purposes good not a beautiful
pocket of sunlight they just happened to
come through let me cut to the chase
here
so this is a bar table right
what are you doing a bad table
what would a couple be doing leaning on
it
so so what I'm getting at is the
environment the light the location the
hair the dress will tell you what to do
that's the creative trigger and again
it's nothing or inspiringly different
but I guarantee you've walked past these
triggers and totally ignored them so
what did I do well we brought them in
the way tilt the face chin up a little
bit even though that the better quality
of what was coming through here but it
was dappled so I turned the other way
didn't look good
so I backlit them and this was fun
then I'm not a big fan of Flair but I
thought it'd be fun to actually create a
different sequence of shots with a bit
of flair coming in my lens and cup a
little bit closer and then we got that
so the cool thing was that I ended up
doing two series of shots one that was
perfectly saturated like this just
strong saturation and then with that bit
of flare coming through and all that
kind of stuff cool cool
all right what would we most of us do in
this situation think about it it's
pretty obvious but I wanted to spell it
out most people would put the Sun as the
background I feel flash the foreground
so that they didn't wind up squinting in
that Sun yeah and that's just it how
many people do you know and that you've
met and photographers that you met and
you maybe even one of them and what
saying this is a bad thing but you
almost shoot with flash all the time I'm
not saying that's a bad thing I'm saying
that if you use fill flash I'll use a
big strobe on every single image guess
what
your work all looks the same it looks
good but it looks predictably good
there's no heartbeat I you know how some
people will nominate themselves I'm a
natural light shooter on the flash
shooter I'm just a photographer I don't
care what it is if it illuminates I'll
use it so my encouragement to you guys
in the room of those of you at home if
you're inexperienced and it's an easy
approach to say I'm a natural light
shooter I can crank the is oh I don't
need speed lights I don't need anything
allowed to shoot what's there that's
totally fine but what happens if you go
to a church that's too dark what happens
if you go to a church when the priest
says no flash what happens if something
happens to one of your units what
happens if you can't
take your strobe on that mountain or
whatever it may be you need to learn to
use everything really you need to be an
expert at what you do
so that anything gets thrown in front of
you you can actually do so my suggestion
is that yes you can use flash and and I
think many of us half of us would have
done this kind of a shot we backlight
everything we crop the the crap out we
crop the the trees above them isolate
the shadow get them walking having some
fun and so on and so forth but let's
look back at that location again do you
see how there's a hill going up and then
I'm going up again and now that's the
key making me thinking of a couple of
shots the triggers were my perspective I
just said guys I want you to go down
there and I wanna have a look at the
quality of light I saw their long
shadows that looked good then the next
trigger was let me isolate the actual
shot and the next trigger was when the
sun's going down I'm gonna get them on
that hill and I'm gonna stand where they
are and shoot upwards so I'm in this
situation right now and then I need a
silhouette now most of us who do a
silhouette will get the couple looking
at each other like I've showed you a
couple times today looking at each other
for it's touching all that kind of thing
don't get your couple to kiss when it's
a silhouette that's my recommendation if
you get a couple looking at each other
kissing their shadows bleed into each
other there's no luxury the luxury of a
forehead and nose lips and jaw is very
beautiful very sexy very sensual let
alone two people about to kiss or
something like that what I'm getting it
is a silhouette what does that mean
shape I'm showing its shape show shape
give them something to do in this case I
just got them walking so I took this
shot first this might be a nice panorama
might be great for the wall something
like that but don't you think this has a
lot more soul how important is it that I
got him to cross his legs over which
gives him shape see most of us we can
point the toe of the bride bend the knee
shift the weight back arch the back we
get this beautiful shape of a bust waist
hips sexy beautiful makes sense and now
with him we often see the S curve in the
bride with a groom I often refer to it
as the V or the C of these broad
shoulders
and if I bring my legs so in other words
if I stand like this
hang the body down and then move the
body like this my shoulders are brought
it towards a camera I put one leg and I
just bend that knee I don't do it in a
feminine way I just bend that knee
that's creating more of a v-shape and
then how important is that little sliver
of light between his arm and his body
because after all don't we want to know
where our body stops and starts rather
than looking that wide can you imagine
looking that wide make sense and these
are the kinds of things that I'll be
using even showing at WPI about where I
may have started from and where I ended
up and how much of a difference it
actually makes with those little tweaks
baby we haven't seen your beautiful face
for a while any questions or thoughts or
comments it's just really awesome to
hear to hear you talk about the
progression from beginning to end and
these shots especially in that last
series that you took because I think a
lot of us I know I would have probably
stopped after that first one with the
shadow in the foreground as a matter of
fact I was shooting with you at that
wedding take a shot like that and I'm
like and I'm done I like I was very
happy with my shot but it's interest
it's really helpful to hear you talk
about your thought process as you took
that shot and then progressed to get
better and better and better and end up
with that last one with that silhouette
that was mind-boggling
so that is um it's it's really helpful
and a lot of people have mentioned it as
well really helpful to hear your thought
process not just what you do this is
what you do in this situation in this
pose and that kind of thing but to hear
why you're doing that and how you're
thinking that so that we can think for
that on our own too which is really
helpful id0 had asked a question a
little bit earlier if you ever get or if
we ever get feedback from our clients
that you're not really shooting enough
of the ambience or the environment that
you're in I know this in this situation
it's a little bit different but when
you're doing those really close crops or
you're trying to crop up the environment
because you're not in really nice
situations you ever get clients that
will say you know well you didn't really
show where my wedding took place or
where we did our portrait session and
just to kind of go back to what Gerry
had said before that really comes down
to making sure that you work for your
clients and then also work for yourself
so you get the images that your clients
need you get those full length portraits
where you're showing off the historical
nature of what you're photographing get
those first your you're working for your
clients but then after you get your
bread and butter then you can have your
dessert and you can play around and get
some of these more creative crops and
have a little bit fun more fun with the
images so that's that's um a really cool
idea - awesome absolutely guys we're not
we are not parents but we are proud
uncle and auntie - too many people in
the industry but from a blood
perspective I have two nephews and a
niece and my younger nephew and niece I
always tell them do what you have to do
to do what you want to do basically do
your homework pass then you can party
all you want so sometimes you don't
wanna hear from your parents you need an
uncle to come and say - you do what you
have to do to do what you want to do in
other words like Melissa said get the
shots that will make them happy that are
predictable then now you can play all
you want and trust me you can be as
creative but as all you want but if you
don't get those bread-and-butter shots
then that's gonna be a huge problem
alright guys and I can't I can't tell
you enough and we read or read enough
about how important it is to slow down
slowing down I know that's probably the
easiest two words you can put together
I'm saying to you though that as far as
the advice that I have after teaching
now for 18 years and shooting
professionally for 25 years the biggest
problem that I see with most
photographers who I know can get better
almost overnight is to take west shots
slow down and do them better I'm telling
you that will be that'll be the if you
have to print out a label a sticker put
words slow down stick on the back of
your camera so when you put your camera
to your eye it reminds you to slow down
trust me it's the best advice I can give
you alright let's move on so this is a
recent wedding in Melbourne that we did
so what was the trigger here I'm gonna
ask my audience members here what was
the trigger the this was basically the
coordinator preparing to enter and
escort all the bridal party into the
actual reception venue but here I am
doing my test shot to basically
photograph to photograph the the the
bridal party walking in but I saw this
location I thought wait a second there's
a
ready trigger what am I gonna do now
what what do you think I did with this
location when I had five minutes and I
took the couple out of the out of the
actual room and said hey guys I've got a
great idea I want to do this what do you
think I saw here that was a trigger this
one this one so what are you so what do
you see here what he said so give the
microphone for me just a gigantic
softbox
okay so what would you do but where
would you put the couple I'm not saying
you're right and I'm wrong with vice
versa but I'm curious to know what idea
that gave you probably put them near not
very close to the class but near the
glass just enough so that you get some
light coming through it onto their face
okay so there's nice light coming
through here and there but we could just
get them really close and use it as a
translucent diffuse oh that's what
you're saying great idea absolutely
great credit trigger what else Jay talk
to me as yours as you were pointing up
there you can see the guy with the
suspenders through so you can get kind
of a silhouette if you want to put them
on the other side as well okay now we're
talking wait a second so you're seeing a
bit of an abstract sort of shadow here
silhouette yes so I could sit on this
side and shoot that way right so what
else could I do other than just get them
ahead face-to-face like most of us would
do and probably would which would suit
this shot quite quite obviously think of
a problem what do you do at a wedding
what do you how do you celebrate what
prop could could celebration give me as
an idea glasses champagne
wait a second holy [ __ ] oh did I say
that word sorry that's gonna be the
first of many you just we got it out
there it's fine
we all say it just it's fine yes
what I'm thinking is we get a couple of
champagne glasses and what I love about
this is that the actual diffuser let's
call the diffuser actually mutes all the
colors but the only colour that I'll see
is the one that's costs enough to the
actual material so I get this one that
ended up being the title page of their
wedding album make sense most of us I
guarantee would be sitting there
freaking out waiting to get
right exposure for the couple to walk in
the reception venue but you have to be
on the prowl you have to look you have
to search you have to recognize those
creative triggers Melissa
unless you're showing me your armpit no
I actually have a question that I'd like
to ask that no one knows to ask because
I was at I was photographing this
wedding with you and what I learned when
you took this image is actually I saw
that you were gonna take a silhouette
and I just thought to put them behind
there but can you talk about where you
position them to get that sharp of a
that great of a reflection if you know
where I'm going with the silhouette yeah
I mean they were they were exceptionally
close to the glass because they will if
you win an inch further away it would
just blend in and bleed out into nothing
so it's literally go as close as you can
to the glass without touching it and
that's what I recommend because
sometimes you might get an abstract face
like going really close and then adding
contrast to it but the minute you do
this on piece of glass that looks really
weird so it's a tough thing yes my
question for mark from Joe when you have
windows hits you you have a place to you
jump around on on a wedding timeline I
was thinking you could do it before shot
where he's standing on one side she's
standing on the other so it'd be a
before wedding or is it just something
that hits you you kind of go as you go
through the wedding now I regret not
doing that shot that you just
recommended nothing is a great idea now
you're thinking it's fantastic i prime
aynd this was gonna be the title page so
I gotta say the way you disobeyed that
up I'm like you just slapped me in the
face right now I think it's fantastic I
should have got a spread of a wedding L
rather than just a title page because
having let's say her here
maybe sipping the champagne glass and
then him here just looking off quite a
mysterious why would be caught killer so
that's something that I didn't think of
that I probably should have also meant
fantastic alright what about this I walk
in this bedroom there's a lot of mess a
lot of fuss there's a beautiful
reflection in the mirror so what do I do
I position myself right on the edge
I turn around and this is a pretty
obvious trigger the reflection is pretty
obvious but what was not so obvious is
this I thought okay I've got so much
crap all around I want to open up that
door and go nice and tight and get that
beautiful light that sliver of light
tickling her back there and then we get
this shot so sometimes like I said it
could be an obvious location that we've
we've used and we've shot before but
maybe we haven't gone to that extent so
let me show you a handful of spreads of
the wedding album that the couple
actually purchased so this double
beautiful sunlight coming through and we
got this that beautiful tickle of light
I love that little dappled light on her
face then so that was a that was the
first spread of her coverage then that
was the second spread you loved it how
it sort of just goes up then that sort
of leads her eye in and then that was a
detail spread all just using that
beautiful sunlight coming through I
think many of us would not use direct
sunlight coming through a window for a
bride's coverage of a bride wearing a
white dress then where I'm shooting it
very hard to the field here as well and
then that's her adjusting her veil and
that's that as well
pretty cool all right let's keep on
looking at these credit triggers where
would you shoot here what's the creative
trigger where would I play here I mean
obviously it's just a beautiful place
what I'm seeing I'm a texture guy by the
way guys I love touching I love putting
my hand in lentil John and ELISA Cooper
who are neighbors they wash their dishes
with a with a rubber
sponge and it has this little nip these
little nipples on it I'm not what you
call it I'm sorry for one of a better
workers but the sponge had so much
texture on it and I said I would be very
happy if you bought me one as a present
sure enough the time that I saw them the
next time and now as I'm looking at my
computer I'm just touching this sponge
but anyway what does I got to do with
this photograph
I love crunching leaves if it's a hot
day and the leaves are all crunchy I'll
step on them but that's my trigger right
so what I did was this was a bit too
harsh for the kind of soft photograph
that I wanted to
juice so I grabbed more leaves put them
all here stood up on this particular
spot and shot down and I ended up
getting this shot arms off the body turn
the face beautiful soft light beautiful
shape legs and that was it
this is a wedding I shot in Greece last
year one of my best friends growing up
and I said screw it I'm innocent climb
over the church because the church was
really short and I wanted the view they
can imagine these guys are literally
about three four feet away where am I
going to stand where am I gonna sit to
take the photographs of the ceremony and
you might think Jerry do you wear shorts
at our wedding I'm like if I if I'm ever
gonna wear shorts at a wedding it's
gonna be a hundred degree wedding in
Greece where your best friend's getting
married and it's okay that you wear
shorts because some of the guys are
wearing shorts as well so there it is
took this picture the sun's going down
they're getting getting married just
before sunset
so only ahead literally maybe fifteen
minutes of sunlight but I knew when I
was up on that church I thought to
myself the sun's going down
strike the ceremony I'm going to take
some shots with a rock so that I could
see clearly over there and then I
thought behind the church was a field
I'm gonna wait for the Sun to completely
sit and get a silhouette of the church
let me show the environment so can you
imagine this next shot I stood about
there shot back this way and I ended up
getting this shot and again I need a
silhouette I need something that
separates their body parts and so on so
I can basically see between them all
right let's have a look at this next
shot now I see a pocket of light it's
very strong it's very harsh it's very
masculine so am i great dude stand there
in that pocket of light but I don't know
about you buddy looks awkward the gap
between his legs doesn't it just doesn't
feel right to me then I thought to
myself you know what I'm not really
digging him in that shot yet but let me
just cross his legs a little bit but
let's get the bride in the foreground to
make it look a lot more interesting so
tilt the face chin up beautiful shadows
and the cheekbones life is good and then
I thought to myself wouldn't it be cool
to shoot at f-22 like I did that
previous time
and you see how much difference that
makes that's just too abstract he looks
a little bit weird they're completely
out of focus this one is a lot more
interesting let's not waste it you know
what there was a beautiful pocket of
light there she looks amazing there let
me pretend to be a second photographer
press the pause button take a few steps
and walk around and then see something
different so that pocket of light led me
there but as I diagnose the scene there
were other creative triggers that I
responded to in in in a better way this
actor was also in Greece this wedding
that this is our last year two years ago
so that we're walking we had some fun
and what do you think is well it's a
personal opinion but what do you like
the most about say this shot or them or
what they're wearing or things like that
what's beautiful to look at right now
for me it was her back that beautiful
the small of her back the beautiful
texture that beautiful little shadow on
the back of her dress on her body I
thought was beautiful so I thought to
myself I want to photograph her an
excuse to photograph her from behind
what could she be doing
maybe she's adjusting her hair that gave
me an excuse to do something I thought
wait a second all right I want to
introduce the groom now before I stop
and I recreate that pose for any unknown
reason let me do something so I thought
to myself how do I connect them and
build them like a puzzle so can you
imagine I'm photographing her from
behind she's adjusting her hair I want
to put him into the shot and make it
look like a contemporary sort of
editorial kind of picture so I thought
great let me put his hands in his
pockets he's looking away and we get
this image do you notice how I position
him this gap and this gap are exactly
the same then I have this beautiful gap
mirroring what he's doing this is set a
composition which we would say is pretty
boring but then when you off-center it
breaks the monotony and the
predictability of a Center composition
and that's basically it make sense all
right
she can go you can you can do that thing
that you need to do alright give me a
sign like that exhibit under do anything
with it if you don't know what we're
talking about good it's fantastic all
right let's move on I was doing a
boudoir shoot of this girl and this was
quite soft and very playful I thought
it'd be nice to open up the doors allow
the light to flood through you get a
beautiful shot no problem again now what
was the creative trigger what is obvious
a gorgeous girl but what do you think
would be good to feature in this shot
what do you think what's what's the
trigger what's saying what's begging to
be done here shadows absolutely so where
would the shadows be more obvious yeah
but where would I stand to actually see
more of that shadow you would probably
say on the left hand side right also I'm
loving that beautiful headpiece I'm
thinking how cool is that
so what I do obviously I want to be
discreet so sometimes on a more risque
I'm still cover-up naughty bits
especially for weddings and things like
that sometimes you know some brides or
would wear sessions they want to be a
little bit more risque than a problem in
this case I had the idea of actually
placing that beautiful headpiece over
one of her eyes and get that beautiful
little that little pier upwards and then
we just changed our angle and we've got
a completely different shot make sense
now we're in Budapest and were there
with Melissa and she wore this beautiful
dress I'm like you know what maybe I'm
gonna photograph for you now and what is
the trigger here obviously it's a great
location no doubt I mean it doesn't take
a rocket scientist to work out that this
would be a great place to photograph but
what was the trigger and what made me
shoot where and why the window
okay let's diagnose it so it's the
window now would she be standing on the
stairwell what would she be doing so
she'd be sitting on this particular spot
absolutely we actually tried some of
those shots so what we would be good to
put her face where would we put her face
and head and shoulders do you say so the
trigger is do you see these pieces the
ivy is growing in a way where it's
framing the person so I'm thinking I'm
gonna put a head and shoulders somewhere
here if I expose for her perfectly
everything will blow out and look
ridiculous so really it's a silhouette
now because if I darken this exposure
I'll get the detail that I want make it
this beautiful foliage so I thought to
myself let's get a standing on this area
and do a very dramatic classic pose
reminiscent from the whole old Hollywood
days and we ended up getting this image
retain the detail we got a little of it
it's it's a silhouette per se but you
turn to face the light so we get a
beautiful detail on her dress and quite
beautifully is that she had this
beautiful sort of almost of Ivy style
pattern in her dress that actually
looked incredible and we used that this
is also in Budapest beautiful statues
the sun's from behind or what the hell
do I do well I'm sure most of us would
have thought to do something like this
off camera flash I lower my camera angle
shoot upwards and get that beautiful
drama there as well this was in a
beautiful
concert hall isn't right something like
that yeah an opera house in Budapest Zoe
so as you're walking in we've got this
beautiful shaft of light now shaft of
light Opera House what do you think of
let what's the credit trigger now what
do you think of if I say the words Opera
House Opera Broadway what are you what's
what's one of the most famous shows in
the history of mankind
but think of it I'm trying to get you
think it's a bit of a different way now
so think about like opera what does that
word trigger you what does that trigger
in fact Chris hasn't seen this
presentation yet can we put the camera
on you guys you can so the fan of the
opera right so what I'm trying to say
sometimes the creative trigger will be a
word association so you look at this and
you think fan of the Opera that's what I
thought
so I thought if you've watched it you'll
see there's genetic pictures of the
girls that are running away and this
beautiful glowing and and that gave me
that idea I'm not saying it's Jesus that
I thought of that idea but you have to
commit to something you see something
it's an idea you commit to it and go for
it the difference between good and great
is quite dramatic then I thought well
how cool would it be to actually get a
dramatic picture of this guy with
sunlight coming through a window and
then a dark background this is what you
call Rembrandt lighting Rembrandt
lighting people just think it's just 3/4
lighting and the shadow on the side of
the face Rembrandt lighting is either
one eye or both eyes are in shadow and
you usually get a triangular piece of
light in the face in this case it's very
masculine it's what we consider more
Rembrandt lighting it's a masculine
quality of light now what Chris did
before he put it he put his hand over
his face emulating the mask that the
phantom wore I thought perfect normally
I would put both the couple in a pocket
of lights let me suggest his presence
and have him just there do you see how
we can see a hint of him there but the
metaphor of that Opera gave me the idea
to actually having that it's almost he's
almost wearing a mask of shadow don't
you think it's suggestive and that's
what I loved about the idea of doing
these kinds of things so guys we are
going to finish off with a lots of
announcements lots of cool stuff but
hopefully you guys at home and you guys
here in this particular room you're
starting to think about photography
maybe a little bit a different way
meaning that I've given you to lots of
two perspectives one is the next time
you see pockets of sunlight you'll treat
them differently look at them
differently the next time you walk past
a silver piece of metal reflecting off
Sun what are you going to think of make
sense the next time you see a glow of
light coming underneath the stair rail
what are you going to think of the next
time you walk pass a street with a big
sign of a Hollywood movie poster but
there's floods of light coming through
what are you going to think of the next
time you see the Sun setting and you're
on a hill what are you going to think of
so not only do I want hopefully that
what we've taught you today giving you
specific ideas it's unlocking the
principles behind recognizing triggers
in your environments and maximizing them
in a way perhaps that you've never seen
before and guess what it's a lot of fun
and you can sell a lot of it because
you're creating something incredible and
certainly profitability and maximizing
sales we discuss in future episodes but
hope you enjoyed that guys I want to
pass a list of a couple of really cool
announcements hey hope you enjoyed that
video don't forget to click the
subscribe button below so you always
know when new videos are added and
you're always up to date and if you're
like me and you can't get enough jump
over to gyo Descamps and sign up for
jira kione's photography training where
you'll have access to hundreds and
hundreds of hours worth of educational
content Plus business and marketing tips
lots of great workshops and photo
sessions from fashion shoots portrait
sessions weddings and so much more
see you there
[Music]